foreign
[Music]
Canada you don't want to miss out I'm in
Ottawa tonight Ottawa the capital of
Canada at the arena at TD place don't
know what TD stands for but that's what
it is then I'm sold out in Montreal and
sold out in Hamilton but I will be in
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania October 19th
Cleveland Ohio October 20th October 21st
Detroit at the Jack White theater where
they're so mad at me for
uh they used to do a festival there and
they're not doing it for the first year
and instead on the date it's you it's me
and everyone thinks it's my fault even
though it's not my fault I had no idea
about that thing great also that that
Festival would still be going if people
uh if people bought tickets to it and
they obviously don't so anyway uh
Orlando Florida November 10th uh at the
Walt Disney theater November 12th Fort
Myers
November 17th Richmond Virginia November
18th Baltimore Maryland and then
Philadelphia and then reading for some
reason so I'll be there go to the Don't
Push Me Tour we got dates coming up I'm
also going to be in Trenton New Jersey
at some point soon in December I haven't
announced it yet so be be ready and then
a whole slew of dates for next year
coming up soon before you know it uh
we've got the beautiful merch here uh
the absolutely gorgeous merch here the
uh the pockets stay deep which is the
ones that I'm actually wearing them
right now I got the pocket stay deep
with the diving board on the side of the
pocket there the sweats just kick
kicking in for the winter and the um and
the Beautiful Beautiful uh other ones
that we got here slips my mind for a
second what do we got here what are we
gonna do ones what is it
them
grow or Die the absolutely beautiful
grow or die across the back of the
shoulders let them know when you're
walking away it's all about the grow or
die movement and the uh life rips so
chrisley.com for all that stuff tickets
and merch I see you at the shows with
the merch uh and come to the show for
exclusive merch okay let's get into it
uh welcome to the new hot
episode
[Music]
dude that makes me think of once I was
in Houston and I can't remember I was on
the road opening for somebody I can't
remember I might have been with Tom
Arnold
[Music]
and uh the host was like what do you
want me to say about you and I was an
up-and-coming comedian so I was like
just say I'm like I'm I'm an
up-and-coming comedian I'm like a a hot
Rising upcoming comedian or whatever you
want to say I don't care and uh the guy
was like okay and he kept saying you
know this next comedian he's hot
and uh he's got and I'm like dude does
he think that I said say that I'm like
sexy
so I never correct I didn't correct him
because I didn't know
that's what he was doing until it was
like the last show I was like oh that's
what he's thinking because I would go on
stage I would do my ACT I would do like
20 something minutes and I'd come back I
forget about it by then but anyway
um
that's what happened uh
where is it oh here it is my magic mind
Shake It Up nice to stay on the level my
babies magic mind drinking it
down it we love it
keeps me leveled keeps me nice I can I'm
able to go to weddings and not want to
blow my brains out but anyway
um
I was in uh Edmonton and also
uh Calgary dude it was nice man I mean
Edmonton and I I'll probably post a
video of the stand up oh by the way I
have new stand up out there on my other
YouTube channel uh where I'm kind of
making fun of this dude in Arkansas when
I was in Little Rock go check that out
but by the way I got uh Edmonton is a
crazy place I don't know what's up with
a Calgary I get I don't really get it
Edmonton I don't get it it's beautiful
but also there's many many many like
it's it's kind of methy in a way does
Canada have math I always think of South
for meth Canada has Beth Canada has big
math actually Canada has crazy heroin
too in Vancouver
um I I know that because I was in
Vancouver and I took a left and then I
saw a bunch of heroin and meth addicts
so anyway
um
uh uh
so I was there we we had great shows
Denny and Lulu uh and we had we were so
fun you can check the tour report on
there and Crystal on the Chrisley
YouTube channel uh but we had so much
fun and we loved it dude uh uh I love
Canada man you know I know there's a lot
of stuff in the news about how it's
being really woke but man they don't
give a [__] they really don't I went up
there I did all my [__] I did the Don't
Push Me Tour which is hey don't push me
and they [__] ate it up dude I love
Canada I really do I really do and when
I go there I think man I've been to
these places already you know on some of
the places like last time I was in
Edmonton I played a smaller venue I
played a bigger venue now hey look at
that 2019 I played a smaller venue and
then 2023 I play a bit bigger venue you
know what I mean so look at that man we
sold more tickets
but it's all good it's okay it's okay
dude
Mr fell off all the way up that's how we
that's how we do it now
um so
so yeah so we did that and it's really
cool and it's fun and dude just the
Canadians are so so nice god dude
Canadian
dudes oh they all think they're Drake
hey dude Drake
really
[__] Canadian dudes up you know what I
mean he they just became different once
he got bigger
wood strikes started coming out and
being like I only crying from my mama
[__] it you know or whatever the [__]
those songs you know only person in my
bed is my dog [__] these hoes like dude
men
men from Canada just went like oh dude
oh I'm not cool huh
and then grew a beard cut the top of
their head a little bit more so the
beard was a little bit longer
and just got those [__] slopey shoes
you know that they that you slide in the
boots the slopy slide in boot [__]
shoes that guy's wear that think that
they're so good and Tighter black pants
like uh jeans and then like a shirt and
a flanner over it over it I mean even
like pasty white dudes got thick God
they think they're Drake but they're so
clean and so nice looking everyone's so
nice looking in Canada except for the
really ugly people but everyone's just
pretty much so nice looking but it's
hilarious dude who thinks they're Drake
dude
I mean I go to Cactus clubs all across
the all across the uh the Canada
whenever I'm in a city I go I find the
Cactus Club dude the Cactus Club is a
good restaurant I go there dude I don't
care I eat there I go there I get the
Cajun chicken sandwich you think I won't
I will I do
and I do that and I eat the cake the
chicken sandwich that's not enough I
also order something else right and
that's me
that's Mr bottomless pit okay and I'm
doing that and I eat that stuff and
everyone there thinks they're Drake and
the women are beautiful in Canada it's
fun it's absolutely crazy
there'll be like a uh parking attendant
and you're like God okay
parking attendance in America
trolls
parking attendants in Canada turn around
let me see what you're working with
okay
um
turn around in that Booth you know what
I'm talking about
did a 360 in that booth hey sweetie real
quick sweetie doll look the other way ah
do you know what I'm saying in Canada
there'll be a [__] gate agent not
even the stewardess the gate agent
at the Air Canada ah sweetie doll
turn around look at the screen for a sec
let me see what you're working with oh
the gate agents in America trolls
right
it's crazy
but can it Drake [__] those dudes up
because now they're all I don't know man
everyone you know it's like
but Canada is great
[Music]
um
there's no Wi-fi uh on the Canadian
flights that I was on and my
[__] gosh dude
my [__] gosh
that whole thing that Louis CK said was
like relax we're two you know 30 000
feet in the air it's all great
everything's great you're in the air
you're a chair in the chair in the sky
and everyone's like yeah dude that's
right it's awesome
I don't agree with that I love Louis CK
I don't agree with that hey dude it have
Wi-Fi on the planes dude
they didn't have Wi-Fi on the it's a
three and a half hour flight
holy [__] dude
it's
2023. you're gonna make me watch
Transformers rise of the Beast
like I want to text my friends I want to
be on Instagram instead you're gonna
make me watch [__] you know Kramer
versus Kramer on this big of a like for
some reason uh in airplanes they'll have
like all the new movies and then like
Kramer versus Kramer and Thief with Gene
Hackman and you're like uh what
why are these stuck in there
who the [__] wants to be watching Kramer
versus Kramer on the plane just crying
their eyes out on a six inch by six inch
screen eating peanuts dude flights I
understand it's a bus in the sky and
it's public transportation and it's
absolutely shitty but get Wi-Fi dude
the French lady was just like the the
the [__] dude I was because that's
the thing and I was talking about this
on stage I might turn into a bit but
might not I guess I'm doing bits on my
podcast but
uh the lady was just uh we you know
because at 10 000 feet the Wi-Fi
supposed to turn on and in the whole
time I'm like Oh we must not be ten
thousand feet yet
because the Wi-Fi is not on yet and they
must have Wi-Fi because it's 2023 right
last time I checked it's 2023
so where's the Wi-Fi we must not be too
but I already know we're ten thousand
feet up because it's been too long so
I'm like I can't wait till the
stewardess gets here I gotta talk to her
man
and I can't wait to ask her because I
think that there's not Wi-Fi
and when she says it
one of two things either she says there
is a Wi-Fi we'll just we'll get it
figured out or and then and I get to
have Wi-Fi or she says no there's no
Wi-Fi on this flight and I get to be mad
and that's where I live at home baby why
do I feel so comfortable when opposite
because I don't want to feel my feelings
I don't want to feel the
uncomfortability of not being able to
have Wi-Fi for three and a half hours
instead I'd rather be angry yes dude
I'd rather be seething yes dude
so I say uh Hey ma'am
because she's like would you like to
have was it was a French accent but of
course would you like to have uh not
send tomato juice or some [__] you know
and you're like no let me just get a
club soda Abbott of course okay can I
what's the deal with the Wi-Fi dude she
hits me with this you don't know
because I was already prepared to say
when she said
when I said where's the Wi-Fi I was
prepared to whatever she said I was
gonna say but it's 2023. I already had
that on Deck
but she goes you don't know and now I
can't do the 2023 thing
so I'm like where's the Wi-Fi just you
don't know and I said well oh what
and she said this these type of
aircrafts crafts they don't have Wi-Fi
and I say oh but and then I'm in my head
like when I'm gonna say the [__] 2023
thing and really put her in her place
and she's like I said what do you mean
and she said these are crafts it is for
safety reasons they don't have they
don't have the Wi-Fi
and I say oh okay well you know it's
2023 and now I'm just like trailing off
I didn't get to have [__] Wi-Fi
for two three and a half I watched
Transformers rise of the Beast rise of
the beasts sucks donkey balls
dude they have transformers this is the
[__] I don't like dude
they have Transformers that are
Transformers that are cars
and they transform into
robots
okay
and then they have they made so many
different Transformers
what is this [__] this this [__]
sound play I need to buy a license or
something it's not working
is that right
yeah so anyway
they have um
it doesn't give a [__] dude one person
really
um
all right cool man well you know man
it's a nice all the time
um so now they have the robots the the
the the Transformers that turn into
robots which are okay which by the way
you already know it's a Transformer
because it's a huge [__] 18 wheeler
in a jungle you know and it's not
natural uh also it's so beautiful it's
red and blue and [__] you know it's
Transformer um
so
now they go to the jungle and there are
beasts so now they're a robot now
they're now they're
robot
beasts I I don't even understand they're
they're Beast robots that don't that
they transform oh they maximize they get
into turn into bigger so if it's a robot
ape it turns into a Max it transforms
into a bigger robot ape
it's a different species I guess even
though they're not species because
they're robots
so there's Max Maximus Optimus Prime and
then uh Maximus Primal uh
dork
and so then they have the the mixed race
guy who's the lead now and then they
have the the black lady who's in it too
and then everyone else's robots and [__]
and then the movie sucks donkey ball so
it's all good so the movie sucks don't
get both so it's fine you know uh the
only acceptable place it is to watch uh
Transformers rise of the Beast is on the
plane and that's okay dude and that's
all good dude but I watched it
and I had to watch that because there
was no Wi-fi so that's [__] wonderful
man God it pissed me off yeah man so
good
also
um I was talking about Drake what's up
with the new Drake album where it has
Halle Berry uh doused in slime
you can't do that um
gonna get sued
okay so Halle Berry is still firing
shots at Drake after he's picking
folks have been chiming all weekend
about that slime you out it's called
featuring sza One Finance Hallie why why
I was so impressed photo
that owned by Getty Images
um
oh because he asked me and I said no
that's why she added well I ask if you
tend to do what you want to do that
that was the [__] you to me not cool you
get it nice
damn she really really really got
why did he ask her if he was going to do
it anyway that's crazy
um
it's not a good cover I mean I think
it's kind of whatever it's it's kind of
a cool picture no is it real it looks
like AI
it's a real picture because she's
beautiful
um
why wouldn't she want it I wonder why
she did say no
whatever
um
oh dude we I can't believe this we gotta
talk about this
um
we have a complete like this is
absolutely crazy
this other podcast which I've been
hitting
people have been hitting me up about
this for a while I I I I don't even look
at it I haven't looked at it until
recently
it's called shits and gigs podcast in
the UK
they completely ripped off the Log Cabin
idea and the the cult idea and the white
linen and they call their fans babies
it it's so crazy
the hosts of shits and gigs James and
fujad
I mean they completely ripped off the
idea and it's crazy because like I don't
if you want to do the idea I dude I
don't like people always think people
like steal from Comedians and I don't
think that like there's just there's a
lot of thoughts that are the same and
like you know something happens and then
comedians make fun of it and [__] but oh
my God you gotta go and look at the
shits and gig they have like a log cabin
um Retreat that they're trying to do
like that's they're that they're hosting
and they're like come on babies get your
white linen and in this lock join us in
the log cabin and be a cult member and
and it's so it's such a rip-off and it's
so crazy that it's so blatant
but go look at their stuff
I mean look dude I I it's just odd it's
so odd and I finally look because people
were constantly hitting my up about this
look and I looked and because I don't
ever buy that [__] but this is like
crazy dude
um and it's a podcast
and there's other [__] that's similar to
you can go look it up it's called shits
and gigs they say sh x t s and gigs in
gigs
um
but my God
like just say say oh yeah just like
Chris Delia we're doing this do that
I don't even care but it's so crazy to
pretend like it's your idea anyway
um
dude the thing oh it happened the thing
that made me the most mad yay the thing
that made me the most mad yay dude the
thing that made me the most mad in years
yay oh my God I am on a trip from
Calgary to Edmonton or no Edmonton to
Seattle because I connect in Seattle to
go to La Edmonton to Seattle I don't
have Wi-Fi on the plane from Edmonton to
Seattle we've already discussed this
because Air Canada WestJet and Canada at
least for me they did not have it okay
um
and so what happened is I'm now have to
sleep because there's not even a TV yes
dude I'm on a prop plane all good I'm
gonna sleep I have the the window side
so I'm going like this I'm sleeping from
Edmonton to Seattle an hour 40 flight
all right I never sleep on the the plane
I'm able to sleep on this plane I pass
out I'm leaning on the side of the plane
and I am visibly passed out my eyes are
closed my mouth is hung open all right
and I keep I know I'm assuming because I
keep doing this
foreign
and now I'm in the winter scene which
means there's somebody next to me I do
not know this person all right it's a
woman I do not know nice to sit next to
sweet sweet person didn't bother me we
didn't even talk right
I get this I'm on the side I'm going
what do you think about this okay I'm
leave it in the comments I'm like this
I get this
I look up
there's a guy in the um
aisle
so now I know we're going down right
because that's the only reason to wake
me up if it's just some guy
okay it wasn't a stewardess it was some
guy and he's psychic and he has a
premonition about we're going down and
the premonitions have worked out before
this
and he's got a good track record and he
knows that I have to stay safe so he
wakes me up to get into the crash
position so I'm so happy he woke me up
so I say to him yeah
I'm asleep I'm like out too I say yeah
and he says hey are you the comedian
foreign
so I say yeah and he says Chris and I
say yeah and he says can I get a picture
first of all
how
that's my first question hey guy
how hey hey guy don't turn me into an
Indian chief but
how
okay
racist
so I I say I think about this there's a
woman next to me
what's the pick gonna be is she gonna be
in it is he gonna do like this she's
gonna be in it do I get out
if I'm awake this is [__] bonkers
so I say he says can I get a t can I get
a picture and I say I'm sleeping man
and then he says please
and I say again I'm sleeping man
and he says okay sorry
then travel now this was the worst part
travels the rest of the way to the
bathroom didn't get up to do it
decided to bother me on the way to do
something else yo that is the most and
here's the thing about being you know in
the know or whatever you want to call it
a celebrity it sucks because
he could easily be like wow Chrisley is
a dick wouldn't take a picture with me
nobody would know the story
he walked me the [__] up dude
how crazy is that yo oh guess if I fell
asleep after that because of however
because I guess if I fell asleep again
after that because of how mad I was
guess if I was able to to just kind of
quell it and let it simmer I guess if I
was able to do that or not oh I wasn't
dude
I really want to have a conversation
with that guy that's nuts
could you [__] believe that
I'm sleeping it wasn't like I was
hunched over I was like this
there's some [__] in the comments
that's gonna be like well you know you
could have gone up you know no
people are just they don't know any they
don't know people don't understand stuff
you know
like I was I sat I walked by a a
restaurant it's a cafe it's a
and my two friends were there and I was
like oh you guys know each other and
they're like yeah and I was like I'm
gonna go get some food I came back out
and I sat next to the um I sat next to
them not on at the same table they're
like you could sit at the table I was
like No just sit here it's a bigger
table whatever so I was like with them
but not with them you know
and then uh
uh at my table which was empty but me
um another guy says hey can I sit here
and I know the guy from the gym
so say of course buddy he says cool so
I'm talking with my other Buddies
uh George Janko and Keegan Allen that's
what they were
and so I'm talking to them
and they're talking about Alex Jones
So Hot Topic right we're talking about
conspiracies
conspiracy theories and how we think of
them
I'm talking to Keegan I'm talking to
George
the guy sat down with us the guy who sat
down with us
that I didn't vouch for but I'm like you
know yeah of course I know this guy from
the gym you know he says you know what I
think
and I say I told it to my wife and I say
yo yo hold up
[Laughter]
I say before you say anything and I turn
to Keegan and George and I say just so
you guys know I don't know this guy he's
a gym bud I like his energy seems nice
as [__] but I don't know him now proceed
okay
[Laughter]
because this is a topic I can't have
this guy being like well the frogs are
gay because of the water and Joe Biden's
a lizard and then these guys I gotta
wait a whole conversation to be like I
don't really know that guy I don't want
to sit through that
I don't want to sit through that so
Whoopsie Daisy I had to put a wall up
is like you can't do that [__] and I was
like no dude absolutely not
this is the rules
if we you know we don't know each other
at the same level I learned this when I
was at the [__] when you're at comedy
clubs and you're just hanging out with
the friends and the Fellas and then all
of a sudden somebody walks up and
they're like hey you know what happened
to me and we're like who are you
it's like [__] if Barry Bonds came
back from the batting Circle and went
into the Dugout and you were just like
oh dude it's crazy man when I play
baseball this happened or you know and
dude you're in the audience
so you gotta check people now I didn't
check them in a shitty way I was like
seems nice has a nice energy I like the
guy but now you can go and then they
started talking and I just [__] just
Charlie Brown's teacher because they got
involved and I was like oh dude I'm out
they're all were involved and I was like
I'm out maybe they're best friends now I
have no idea
um but I told this to my wife she's like
you can't do that I was like man I guess
that's just where we differ she's like
because I wasn't even being a dick
that's the thing that we get into
arguments about sometimes is like how
I've got a tone and it's like dude I'm
just from the [__] East Coast really
right because I say Mario and not Mario
like I got a tone
because I say orange instead of orange I
got a tone because I say forest instead
of forest I gotta top
I dude I'm gonna ruffle I'm gonna
wrestle some feather feathers right now
that LA Rams thing
where the AI robots were
yeah you know it oh you have not seen
this
oh wow have you wow
the movie The Creator
uh
uh that comes out with Denzel not Denzel
Washington whatever the son's name is
Isaiah Washington John Washington I
don't know George Washington
um
they did a promo where they introduced
AI robots into the stands and walking
around on the field at the LA Rams game
okay now everyone is like oh my God look
it's really happening this overwhelming
like this is crazy can't believe how
real they look look at them this is
unbelievable wow overwhelmingly they're
saying oh my God this is crazy how they
did that now
guys
it's obviously [__] people in there
hey guys it's people
and and I know people don't believe that
they're gonna be like no way dude how do
they
hey
if AI was that good already it wouldn't
take the [__] a movie
to like fund this Expedition
there's so much wrong with this thinking
it's unbelievable
they pull one over on you and it's all
for promo so fine dude they're walking
around like people you they have you
seen the latest robots look up real life
Ross it's like some [__] idiot woman
with no hair just like I uh like
cheesecake
cheesecake is my favorite dessert
you think
that they just have eight AI robots that
literally are like hey how you doing hi
I'm a person hey what's up walking
around taking in football walking around
on the field
do you know how much that would cost you
think first of all the movie The Creator
broke that uh news that now there's AI
walking Among Us
and that they spec dude how much would
that go there were like six of them at
least how much would that cost
30 million dollars and they didn't do
that
they're [__] people dude
you dumbos
my cat my videographer Sam was like no
way they're not people I was like oh Sam
they got you
I mean dude they're just they're like hi
and these people in the stand are so
dumb they're like hi and the person in
the AI suit is like this
dude because you know who's in there
Ralph
I mean and I know people are gonna be
like dude no no no and no there is no I
go I watched the thing that same story
because ah Sam this is people and he was
like no way you're being a contrarian no
it's [__] people watch the video dude
play a little bit of it you know but
dude it's just so
I don't I don't know ai's scary as [__]
it's scary as [__]
like what's going on over there AI
bro how hilarious is that Mercedes-Benz
made the [__] jumping mode to get out
of sand who's buying Mercedes to drive
through sand
they made a jumping mode where if you
get caught in sand you can just jump out
of it like the Mercedes just goes like
like kind of like Hydraulics and it
jumps out
and of course obviously people are just
doing it in the streets
because it's dope looking
like look at this [__]
the Mercedes-Benz just creates a special
jumping mode to rescue us
and then they're just in the street dude
and if you think I'm not gonna get one
of these [__] cars you're absolutely
out to lunch I'm getting one of these
and I'm bouncing everywhere
but if the ever some of these Cliffs
were just at people [__] in the car
and nobody knew that's dope dude look at
the way they're doing it I wish every
car did this
peacocking at its finest huh
unreal
I saw that movie Flight were they uh
where they landed the plane upside down
and then
this is the thing the problem I have
with
Hollywood based on a real story [__] the
[__] thing was nothing like what
happened you know
just don't say based on a true story
don't do that it makes people it's such
a sucker move people go oh really I
gotta go see that and then they like add
vampires
and you're like well it was based on it
and then we just introduced the you know
the guy who did it upside down it flew
upside down and then landed I guess and
and I was looking it up
and apparently there were different
articles where they said everyone died
but then he saved some people I thought
flight based on true story
um the events of the film were inspired
by true events involving a pilot
actually inverting a commercial airplane
in order to stabilize and save the lives
of Muslim Adventure so there you go
and then uh
I'm drunk now
I'm drunk right now dude that's the
[__] meme
at 11 A.M hey are you gonna drink
tonight I'm drunk now
I'm drunk right now so funny
but look at this Landing here
oh sideways
oh
my god dude
oh wow
landed sideways like he's like he's in
[__] Cobra and the GI Joe
oh my God
I'm my last that's what would be I would
be like I'm [__]
and then and then we would make it and
I'd be like oh well okay
I mean just sideways dude unreal uh God
bless huh
God bless
all right guys I got your hauler.baby uh
I got your hauler baby uh things right
here we're trying out this new thing on
hauler.baby you can go to holler.baby
slash crystallia where I do these really
uh quick little reads for you guys we're
testing this out seeing how it's going
um and here are some of them and some of
them I don't even know if they're real
or not but uh this is what we got so uh
Ryan Miller would like for you to check
out thirsty Goose portable bedside
urinal for Med at uh thirsty Goose dot
Co dude are there really those I'm
getting one maybe because I I want to
just be able to roll off and just tinkle
out the side
um check out at Daisy Dazzle dreams for
all your custom themed spiritual and
healing goodies that's absolutely uh
that sounds like a yeah so that's a
crazy person but it's okay dude it's
okay uh Daisy dazzled dreams uh that
whole thing sounds insane but there you
go if you're into that stuff Great Kyle
Huddy I love you Dingus love B that's
cutest cutest [__] that's from Bianca
there need another podcast give Jared
and Jared a try today no don't do that
but they're saying do it so that's the
ad
um need a great brand video content need
great brand video content go to scout
uh straight Dash what is that Dash
hyphen Scout hyphen creative.com check
out the band scooped up if you dig pop
punk
we make high-end animations even for
podcasts visit jayvarta.com we gotta do
that
here's another one go check out the
z-listers podcast
nice name I like that name
basic honey the only honey and candles
for my babies nice I like how they added
my endorsement in there even though I've
never had it before but anyway
appreciate you guys go to holler dot
baby slash crystallia if you're
interested in buying a little ad or a
shout out
okay had to pump some air in here for a
little bit
um
this thing was crazy
how they kicked out Lauren bobert out of
showing of Beetlejuice the play don't
close yet well it's got to be a musical
right
uh Beetlejuice Beetlejuice Beetlejuice
um don't you have to say his name isn't
that what it goes yeah three times
what's that say my name three times
saying that there's like so many
different stories was like you say his
name three times and then
like Candyman
who else Bloody Mary that yep yep yep
yep that's what started it all
uh sitting U.S congressman Lauren bobert
so she was at Beetlejuice the musical
oh my head so small
um and
what the [__] the guys have dinosaur and
um
her husband her boyfriend boyfriend was
uh basically jiggling her titties uh and
they got kicked out jiggling her titties
and also she had her hand down his pants
stroking all good weird to do at a
musical when you're dressed all nice
um you know what I mean like in a movie
theater I get it like if you're going to
see [__] Transformers okay but get
going two you're having a night out you
know what I mean you're having a night
out in a nice sequence dress the guy's
got a sport coat on and you just start
stroking right
that's a little much and you're vaping
which is so annoying the most egregious
thing here is the vaping don't be
puffing out plumes of smoke add up
anywhere where people are sitting next
to you it's so annoying
people who vape near me dude some people
pull out a vape when I'm driving I go
like this roll down the window and then
say yo could you roll the window up and
I say now now you're put now if you're
puffing up plumes of smoke baby
you want me to Smart you want to smell
like chemical strawberries up in here
keep that [__] in your lungs and outside
of my car dude so so she was stroking
him off he was getting jiggly with the
damn titties right now we're doing
everything that couples doing it's all
good my baby it's all good did jiggle
some titties it's all good to get
stroked okay and it's kind of okay to do
it in covertly in a place and maybe this
is their Kink maybe they like to do it
in public and he's not taking their
titties out she's not taking the tip out
she's not doing these things right
but they got kicked out because she was
vaping which is super annoying and
singing which is super annoying and
taking selfies which is basically this
she's a basic she's basic okay and this
is terrible this is so annoying and the
dude was probably just all like us is
awesome dude oh hell yeah got
congressman's titties watching
Beetlejuice dude
no way stroke it a little bit
um so they were doing that and they were
having a good time he was getting all
spunked out right and then they threw
him out and now
this this kind of [__] is the [__] I
hate surveillance video of Lauren bobert
kicked out of the Beetlejuice of
Beetlejuice in Denver
for reportedly vaping singing recording
and causing a disturbance Congress your
turn like like that's a [__] booted
out of Congress that's a this anybody
who first of all there's video
surveillance of this hey Salem this is a
sex act almost well you can't say it's a
sex actors and that will be illegal but
like dude what about the fact that
yeah I probably can't sue him but this
just sucks that now she's being
humiliated and she's going to want to
[__] jump off the Eiffel Tower and uh
and now
the left is like you gotta kick her out
but also they're cool with you know
trans women showing their titties on the
White House lawn so it's like
you know what I mean
I don't like how it's all at war no
matter what it's like it's either okay
to do this [__] or it's not it doesn't
matter what you believe
if you're squeezing titties in public is
it okay or not because if you're on the
left and you're screaming about hey she
can't be squeezing titties and be in
Congress then it's not okay for Joe
Biden to let trans women honk their
titties on the White House floor right
Warehouse lawn
um
because this is the thing too because
they're like it's everything is
empowering to women everything is
empowering to women unless you don't
like the person and then oh she's being
a [__]
who hasn't done this [__] by the way you
know
who hasn't done this [__] square ass
[__] I don't give a [__] I
don't know and I didn't even know she
was right or left until I saw the
[__] news about her I was like oh I
get it it's the Liberals that are mad
um
but yeah dude look at this video of it
he's honking them titties dude
and she didn't got kicked out the video
the recording thing is what you get
kicked out for they were like man you
have to go why actually him honking your
titties is fine but you were recording
and we can't do that that's interesting
that's IP that's another intellectual
property
it was the fact that your stroking his
tip that's fine I don't really care
about that I come here and I see plays
all the time my wife struck my tip but
you have to leave because of the
recording
he's fine
um and then she writes I'm a Christian
so they may how tone deaf is this tweet
I thought it had to be a joke I am a
Christian so they may try to drive me to
my knees but that's where I'm the
strongest oh
great now I'm horny dude you can't say
that period but you can't say it after
you got tossed out of Beetlejuice forget
your titties closed
that's a [__] position
and I thought it was a joke until she
wrote after that time to get your minds
out of the gutter guys we're talking
about prayer here hey you put our minds
in the gutters
it started with squeezing titties
I started with stroking tips
it started with hiding your hand
and now you're gonna be all like hey get
me on my knees I'm trying to suck a guy
off hey get your mind out of the good
I'm a Christian dude they're trying to
drive me to my knees with my mouth open
but that's where I'm the strongest
sucking hey guys
I'm talking about prayer here
ah I wonder what will happen she'll
probably be okay
I didn't know that people in Congress
had such nice racks dude
honestly being for real but then they're
trying to go after Harold's Howard Stern
because
um
he's like I don't this whole thing
he says she's a disgrace to the country
and I listened to it a little bit he's
they're making it sound a lot worse than
it is
but uh it's so weird that Howard Stern
got a huge got famous for you know
objectifying women
with Jimmy Kimmel
no was that was he on the man show ever
Howard Stern where Jimmy Kimmel part of
that [__]
Kimmel was a part of what they Stern
no Kimmel was got it I get them confused
because Jimmy Kimmel was the same thing
he had that [__] man show and now
he's like so liberal but like Howard
Stern is
wow he says being called woke is a
compliment
I'm not for stupidity it's crazy dude I
feel like that if he didn't
do that he would have got so dragged
into the [__] me too [__] right Maybe
not maybe he's on the level I have no
idea
I've only heard he's a really nice good
guy I never met him
um but that's so crazy to make your like
to cut your teeth on the objectifying
women
like
and then be like yo
somebody on Con in Congress can't hook
up
like they're not priests and even
priests dude hey priests
come on
well most priests are you know a lot of
priests do it because they're gay but
like the presets are straight hey
sup dude come on get it wet a little bit
right hey I get it how how are that
father thy name whatever the [__] it is
but also get it wet a little bit right I
get it you know chastity belts and
whatnot but yo a priest let's get it
going in the [__] horizontal
Department am I right or what I know I
know I'm going to hell but also priests
you know what I'm saying
get at least stroked off a little bit in
a movie theater that's all I'm saying
right enough with the [__] you don't
you know I know that the Catholicism was
rampant with the [__] the pedophilia
and the and the and the little boys stop
doing that obviously and if you're gay
cool but [__] adult men and then also
get it wet a little bit right you know
what I'm talking about priests
the the the the celibacy thing is crazy
the whole I don't have sex with nobody
that's crazy dude
sex feels good dude you ever have that
It's So Dope every time you have it
you're like oh yeah this
you know
I it's so weird every time you have it
you're like oh
I think your mind does something like
after you don't do it for even a few
days and then you're like and then you
do it after that and you're like oh yeah
I forgot it was this dope we gotta do
this more often you know you think that
with your wife and [__] we gotta do this
more often
yeah man like you have those thoughts in
your head even besides the thought guys
thoughts during sex is always oh man
this is so hot but then also you think
regular thoughts like oh man we got to
do this more often or something like oh
the pillows are in the wrong place you
know you still think real thoughts but
then you go we gotta do this more often
[__] man
and you turn on something with the new
show with Matthew good or whatever the
[__] up move that movie is with the
lady that looks like the girl from
[__] Vampire Diaries not Vampire
Diaries what's the other one Twilight
Zone what the [__] the Twilight Twilight
movie Twilight Jesus Christ and [__]
that up huh
I'm a grandpa
um
the witch zone or whatever that [__]
that new movie is called it's a show
it's a show god dude I'm getting old man
I can't wait to like I got a little bit
of gray hair I want my hair to be gray
as [__] I want to be a silver fox I
don't like just the gray in my beard I
want this to come through you know what
I need to do I need someone to scare the
[__] out of me
I need someone to just [__] go boo
around the corner I go oh and I go right
I'm gonna die I'm gonna die I've never
dyed my hair one time in my life I'm
gonna diet once it starts getting gray
I'm going full Raiden
doesn't know it
yeah
but where you at with it I need you at
this store dude stop playing with me
give me a date
oh no it's this phone
the worst Whose Line Is It Anyway
still doing it
go and do like official in-store I need
to know ASAP Chicago no problem I got
you but Balvin you've been telling me
that you got me I need to know what day
on your calendar
all right I'm gonna check the calendar
today your Balvin let's do it man put me
in the calendar the worst improv dude
the worst Improv
not ever getting past his one part of
saying yeah but we got to make a date
though you know never moving never
moving it Forward
come to Miami Southeast 7th and Congress
we the best store we got your sneakers
man and when they come out the whole
world gonna come get them but I want
them to see you I want you to touch the
people not just that you know we got
that thing we working on together you
know I I can't tell you know it's a
surprise but you know we got
Bonita
change the name of your shoes the new
name of your shoes is called dentist
the J Balvin sneakers are called
dentists dude
that was the worst improv I've ever seen
in my life
dude how about imagine that's his
[__] Groundlings audition that's his
Saturday Night Live audition
dude
um
starts he starts himself doing Spanish
and then gives up halfway through and
also never moves the bit
past the first line and even switches
places and is still not moving it only
moves it physically
um
we the best
minutes
stop playing with me give me a date oh
no it's this phone Batman I need you at
the store give me who's filming it you
know right now
are we going to do this in store you
know I got your sneakers going all right
guys so bad you know God dude what the
[__] is DJ cow gonna be like when he's
75.
ah enough of this [__] everybody's
famous great everybody's famous
um all right that's good for now I
appreciate you guys uh reading
Philadelphia Pittsburgh Baltimore uh uh
Richmond Virginia
uh Philadelphia I said that already
um I will be there Ottawa tonight
Canada and then a bunch of other dates
uh chrislea.com go get that merch it
looks nice look your boy's wearing it
right now
yup yo Balvin where you at yo Balvin
look at the pocket stay deep yo yo
Balvin hold up wrong phone yo Balvin we
got the diving board right above the
pocket right there that's where the cash
go yo Balvin so go get that chrisley.com
let them know your pockets
and I spit all over the place when I did
that but um appreciate you guys and
leave a comment uh that's it for the
YouTube uh show if you want to watch the
rest the uncut version of the podcast go
to patreon.com crystalia also uh go get
the two three years worth of extra uh
episodes that we have on patreon that
will be unlocked the moment you
subscribe for only six dollars and uh go
do that patreon.com crystallia and also
it helps us keep this show going I
really appreciate it I appreciate you
guys thank you
foreign
[Music]